الهتافات المؤيده لحزب العمال الكردستاني
ودعوات له
لثائر مما حصل اليوم ضد المركز الثقافي
الكردي يعني اشير ميسون لو سمحت لي وتفضل
يلاحقا باعاده طرح سؤال لك همم الجمعيات
الحقوقيه توضح وهي مستاءه جدا من الافراج
مؤخرا عن المعتدي تتساءل كيف يمكن لمن
اودينا بالقيام بهجوم عنصر على مخيم
للاجئين في الثامن من كانون الاول للصوم
من العام الماضي قبل عام واسبوعين هاجم
لاجئين مسالمين كانوا ينامون داخل خيامهم
في مخيم للاجئين في الدائره الثانيه عشر
في قلب باريس اصيب نتيجه اعتدائه حينها
العام الماضي
لا شيئا بينهما احدهما كان اصابته خطره
كيف يمكن لمرتكب هذا الاعتداء ان يكون حرا
طليقا الجواب هو ان حكما صدر بحقه بعد
سجنه لمده عام او اقل من عام بقليل هو
استانف الحكم الصادر بحقه ما ادى الى
الافراج المشروط عنه هو وضعه تحت المراقبه
القضائيه اذا هو كان حرا ولكن بعد الافراج
عنه بانتظار استئناف الحكم الصادر بحقه
تتسائل الجمعيات الحقوقيه ان عقوبته هجوم
من النوع الذي قام به العام الماضي هي في
القانون الفرنسي عشر سنوات لماذا سجن اقل
من سنه واحده تجيب المصادر القضائيه بان
فتره الحبس المؤقت هي عام واحد وليست اكثر
من عام واحد اذا اتهامات وتصريحات مستنكره
عن منظمات حقوقيه وشخصيات سياسيه
تستنكر التساهل مع مرتكب الاعتداء زعيمه
اقصى توجهت بالتعزيه الى عائلات الضحايا
وزير الداخليه حاول ان يهدئ خواطر
الغاضبين من الاكراد وقال انه جاء الى هنا
بطلب من رئيس الجمهوريه وان كل المراكز
والمواقع الكرديه ستحظى بحمايه خاصه وكل
التراخيص بخروج تظاهرات ستعطى لطالب بها
وغدا الجميع طبعا كما ذكرت قبل قليل
الاكراد هنا يستعدون للمشاركه في تظاهر
يتوقع ان تكون حاشده عند ثانيه عشره من
الظهري غدا في ساحه الجمهوريه لا ريبليغ
بالاضافه الى تظاهره في مرسيليا سجلت قبل
حواله ساعتين من الان بدعوه من الجاليه
الكرديه يتوقع تحرك كردي شامل لا يشمل فقط
فرنسا ميسون انما يشمل عده دول اوروبيه
الجاليه الكرديه في اوروبا اعدادها كبيره
وهي جاريه منظمه ولديها خبره في كيفيه
تنظيم التظاهرات وتنسق في ما بين مجموعتها
بشكل جيد مراره كبيره هنا كيف يمكن ان
يتعرض يتعرض لا هو بعد ان واجهوا الارهاب
ببساله كما يقولون واذا بارهاب من نوع اخر
ومن جهه اخرى يستهدفهم اليوم في باريس
عندما قتل ثلاثه ثلاثه اشخاص في هجوم على
المركز الثقافي الكردي في